doing a new tour there new things you
try to add into the yeah yeah i'm always
uh trying to be as creative and and you
know shocking as possible but i stay in
my lane too
and i'm also like very money conscious
like i'm not one of those artists who
needs crazy ass production we need
[ __ ] fireworks and i'm not that guy
you know what i'm saying i'm trying to
make money right you know what i'm
saying so i'm actually like in those
meetings when they're sitting down and
they're going over how much this [ __ ]
cost and how much you know how much the
production of the show will be yeah
longer it's gonna take to get there uh
you know what venues we're gonna be able
to uh set all of this [ __ ] up at and
some venues if you're gonna have to have
half of the production a lot of people
don't take that [ __ ] into consideration
when they're like planning their events
they're just like
i wanna [ __ ] pop out of hell you know
what i mean and like as an artist like
that sounds cool but you gotta like
be realistic i just saw
i just saw mgk and he had a [ __ ]
helicopter well i don't blame him over
the [ __ ] arena it looked crazy i
don't blame him it was dope it was dude
when you get to that point where you
want to make those decisions
it's a helicopter or it's
bringing money home i'd rather bring the
money home not to say nothing bad about
anybody's business for sure but you know
i love art but i love my business like
i'm a businessman i got into this [ __ ]
to do business dog like you feel me so i
can get my point across with screens and
lights and my badge your energy cryo and
my energy and i got a couple other
little tricks so you got some hit
records
involved yeah you know what i'm saying
and like i'm really one of those people
where even if you don't know the words
i'm still going to entertain you and
bring you in like
i'm that's my duty and job as a
performer you know what i'm saying so
it's been like that since day one and
it's gonna be like that with me being a
multi-platinum selling i'm still going
to invite you in to the record so
you know shout out to all of the crazy
ass production but i know how much that
[ __ ] cost and i don't want it